So the next question becomes, given a set of animals, or in general,
a set of objects or elements, and a set of percepts for each of those animals,
how can we decide what's a good equivalence class for those animals? Consider,
for example, the three animals shown here, eagle, bluebird, and penguin.
Let us suppose that we knew that there are six percepts that are important for
each one of these animals. Lays eggs, has wings, has talons, and
so on. But in order to decide what might be a good equivalence class for
these three animals, we first have to decide on what might be
the right values for each of these percepts for
each animal. So I'm going to ask you to use your background knowledge,
to fill in the values of the percepts that applies to each of the animals.